a lot of people have been wondering like
you know what you've been up to and
they've been you know sending their
prayers out and everything what do you
have to say to those people
just like thinking that you're up to
whatever it is like what do you have to
say to them you say prayers
and think about it really
well thank you
wendy williams speaks out amid reports
about her mental well-being we've got a
lot to talk about on wednesday the
57-year-old talk show host shared a
lengthy message to instagram
seemingly filmed by her son kevin hunter
jr during a walk on the beach in florida
hey mom how you doing hi
so everyone's praying about your thank
you
excuse me i am going back stronger when
kevin mentions to her that her fans are
worried about her health the daytime tv
personality insists there's no reason to
be concerned
56 years old
there are things that happen to people
i would say things usually start about
40
and they go up from there like i want to
be all i can be
and then get back to new york and get on
down with the wendy williams
of course this all comes amid the tv
personality's battle with her bank over
control of her fortune
last week wendy fired back at wells
fargo strenuously denying claims she is
struggling with her mental health after
the bank alleged she is an incapacitated
person who needs a guardianship eti
spoke with attorney mitra ahirian who
does not rep either party
they had some concerns over her ability
to make financial decisions
and they froze all her assets so she
cannot do the simplest things like
pay her bills they really need evidence
that she is unsound mind so what's going
on with wendy well it's unclear but we
do know the talk show host took a hiatus
in 2019 to deal with addiction issues
and in 2017 she fainted live on the air
after having a hot flash but returned
minutes later to finish the show
fast forward to late 2021 and a string
of guest hosts have been filling in for
the past seven months after the show
initially delayed the season 13 premiere
first revealing wendy tested positive
for covid19 then announcing she was
struggling with health issues due to her
graves disease and her thyroid disorder
my thyroid my hyperthyroid is attached
also to
graves disease graves disease squeezes
the muscles behind your eyeballs i feel
like they're birds swimming around my
head
you know like a cartoon
like
constantly high
but not high
at the time the show posted a statement
to instagram revealing that while wendy
was quote making progress she was still
quote experiencing serious complications
now wendy's attorney says holistic
professionals have been helping during
treatment for her conditions adding
quote wendy wants you to know she is
fine she is of sound mind i said what
what as for that guardianship well time
will tell if it's necessary the process
of guardianship requires evidence it
requires proof that requires probing
into someone's capacity which is not a
decision that should be made lightly so
we can expect something like this to
take several months